What comes to mind when you hear the words Napoleon Bonaparte,
emperor of France weighing us against a certain batik corporal in a big horn
hat,
raring up,
majestically on a horse and he conquers half of Europe.
But what if we told you there was another emperor,
Napoleon Bonaparte or Bonaparte who not only managed to rule France for longer
than his famous predecessor,
but basically created modern Paris?
Well,
today you're gonna meet that man,
Louis Napoleon Bonaparte,
a Napoleon the third,
he was the actual nephew of Napoleon as a child.
He was forced to watch the French empire collapse and CS family driven into
hiding as an adult.
He single handedly returns the empire from ruin and then ruled it for 22 years.
He's the man who created modern Paris,
the politician who made France great again,
and the general who led his nation into a ruinous wall.
Napoleon the third.
He was certainly all of these things and many more.
And in the video today,
the story of history is forgotten Bonaparte.
Okay?
On march the 20th 1811 Canon's boomed out across Paris.
Revelers gathered outside the Twitter is Paris.
It was official and burned.
Napoleon had a son had he been old enough to understand the news.
Three year old Shaw,
Louis Napoleon Bonaparte may have felt sadness born on April the 20th 18 or age.
The boy was the youngest son of Louis Bonaparte,
brother of the emperor and Queen Hortense of Hollins.
He,
just to gross you out a little was also Louis Bonaparte's.
Nice.
More important than his parents.
Creepy relationship though was the Louis Napoleon was a potential adds to the
imperial crown along with his older brother,
Napoleon Louie and no,
I didn't screw that up and do eat a polio and the star of our story had an older
brother called Napoleon Louie.
Apparently they thought there just weren't enough French guys running around
with the name Napoleon.
That's pretty good.
Well,
maybe we should just say that he had been an APP prior to that March date in
1811 and burned Napoleon.
He had no legitimate son to inherit the crown.
Now though he no longer had any need for his nephews.
This was tragic.
Not just from the perspective of Louis Napoleon not being emperor,
but also because producing new burner upon was the only reason his parents were
married.
Louie and Hortense,
they totally hated one another by easy in 10 v he couldn't even live in the same
country.
Ends are taken the boys to Paris.
While Louie remains in Hollins,
not the young Louis.
Napoleon saw much of his famous uncle in the French capital,
no longer a likely heir.
He spent the early 1810 simply hanging around waiting for his newborn cousin to
support him as the future emperor and for that to happen,
he did not have to wait very long.
And 1812 emperor Napoleon made the really stupid mistake of invading Russia
belly.
18 months later,
the French amber,
it was in ruins and Paris was under allied occupation realizing that the Jig was
up and desperate to save his dynasty.
Napoleon applicators and made his three year old son,
Emperor Napoleon.
The seconds on April the fourth 1814 but it was at this point that the occupying
allies were pretty much like that's not happening and forced the entire
Bonaparte Line to abrogate two days later on April the sixth before handing
young Napoleon the second over to Austria.
If you started this video thinking Napoleon the third,
what about Napoleon the second?
Where did he go?
Well,
he went to Austria.
That's white.
This not really a video about him.
In the aftermath of Waterloo,
the entire Bonaparte clan,
it was forced into exile Louis Napoleon and his family,
they resettled in Switzerland's where they could do nothing but watch is France,
abolished it empire and restored the monarchy.
It could have been a crushing psychological blow if it were not for queen hot
audience.
From the moment they reached neck.
Sal wholetones started grooming Louis Napoleon and his brother do become future
emperors.
Now,
this was an absurd thing to do,
but it would also turn out to totally be the right move.
On May the fifth 1821 the podium Bonaparte died in exile on center Lena back in
Europe.
The news made all the great powers,
suddenly super nervous about a young Napoleon.
The second so worried where they about this child prisoner taking his father's
mental that they completely overlooked.
Louis Napoleon,
no one noticed is he and his brother moved to Italy papal states in 1826 no one
noticed as they joined the carbon armory lodge and started training and
revolutionary warfare like an audience watching a magic trick.
Europe's great powers were too busy looking the wrong Napoleon.
By the time they realized their mistake,
it was too late.
On July the 20 seconds,
1832 Napoleon,
the second course in pneumonia in Austria and he died at age 21 when the news
hit all surviving members of the burner part line,
we're quick to renounce their claims to the imperial crown.
That was with one exception the year before in 1831 Louis Napoleon's older
brother Napoleon Louie had been carried off by an outbreak of measles that's
men's that the chance to become Napoleon.
The third it passed straight to Louis Napoleon.
His mother's prediction had come absolutely true,
and he was the ad to the French and pot.
So here's the thing about suddenly declaring yourself emperor of France,
it doesn't actually make you emperor of France.
Trust me,
I've tried that is not to say that Louis Napoleon's claim,
I'm like mine was not totally empty.
There was still a large contingency over burnt up artists in France looking to
revive the empire for itself.
It was also unstable in July,
1830 the three glorious days.
It topples the restored borbons and put to the July monarchy on the throne.
While June,
1832 had seen another attempted revolution against the July monarchy.
This Diane involving a lot more show tunes.
It wasn't hard to imagine that for some charismatic leader with a Buddha part
name,
rallying the people of France to his side and overthrowing the government.
Sadly though Louis Napoleon was not that man.
You Seen Napoleon the third.
He was a weird looking guy.
I remember his entourage once described him as a man with a long fat phase,
broad shoulders,
a fast torso,
in a very short legs.
He walked slowly with his feet pointing out and his body tilted to the left
side.
He was also puffed up.
He was pompous.
He was pregnancy prancing around in military regalia,
although he was said to be charming and private.
Europe at large regarded Louis Napoleon is something of a clown and the thing is
here,
he kind of was a clown.
Take this draws book queue as an example,
but our type of the Fed 1836 and leaving Napoleon trying to seize control of the
France by walking into a military garrison and Strasbourg and rallying the men
too is cause instead the garrison commander that had all of the music is
arrested and Louis Napoleon was deported to America.
Not that the exile lasted very long.
They,
in August of 1837 queen Hortense felt seriously ill.
Louis Napoleon caught the first bus back to Europe to be a test side when she
passed away on October the fifth rather than return to America in the way of his
mother's death.
Let me to podium instead went to London.
It was wild in the British capital that he cooked on boneheaded coup attempts
numero do by asking 14th of July monarchy.
It was unpopular looking to prop up and support King Louie.
Felipe arranged have Napoleon Bonaparte's remains reinserted in Paris's lizard
or lead across the channel.
Louis Napoleon mystic,
the celebrations for a sign that the French were crying out for another emperor
Bonaparte.
So on August the fifth 1840 rounds it up the gang of 56 mesenteries and staged a
lending billowing somewhere.
The plan was that the site of Louis Bonaparte,
which inspire the population of France to revolt and overthrow the July
Manicheans then hoist Louis Napoleon up onto their shoulders and declare him
emperor of the French Banstead.
The MRO was once again promptly arrested.
The coup of 1840 was so flagrantly and competence that it probably saved Louie
Napoleon's life.
Leisure,
nor did abouts wrote one doesn't kill a crazy people.
One just locks them up.
There's only [inaudible].
Well,
they agreed rather than death.
Louis Napoleon was condemned to life imprisonment in harm,
fortress,
narrow arms.
Despite his insurrection.
Repas Louie Napoleon's imprisonments.
It was actually kind of comfortable yet a large library and was allowed to read
and write at his leisure.
He wound up learning so much that he took to calling the prison,
the University of arm even managed to write and publish a book.
The extinction of poverty,
which was almost Marxist in its treatment of the poor.
The book became a surprise bestseller in France since earns Louis Napoleon a
strong base of support amongst the workers by 1846 they are living.
Napoleon had grown tired of um,
university on May the 25th he escapes by dressing as a Labor,
errands simply walking out the door.
He,
it resurfaced in London a few days.
Nature urines went back to his impotent Ku plussing.
By now the self proclaimed and Napoleon the third was almost 40 and says nothing
but two failed coups to his name.
It would take a spectacular turnarounds for doing a pony and to fulfill his
mother's dreams and become emperor.
The entire social order of France would have to be exploded like a volcano just
erupted underneath this little.
Anyone realize this as the 1840 is drew to a close a volcano was exactly what
France was sitting on.
Yeah.
How back in 1830 the July Monique,
he came to power in France on the back of a revolution.
Well,
in 1848 it exited Z in exactly the same way.
On February the 22nd 1848 in governments or ban on people meeting for banquets
somehow span off into violent street protests.
This intern somehow led to King Louie for lead,
abdicating the monarchy being abolished and the second French Republic being
declared.
That happens on February the 26th this was the moment Louis Napoleon had been
dreaming off,
not two days later on February the 2080 arrived in Paris and offered the
revolutionary provincial government is help and recurring theme there.
The provisional government said to properly back into exile.
Yeah,
France might have revolted,
but it was not a revolt aimed at putting a Bonaparte Baggins of power.
The New Republican government,
they wanted liberal reform,
not some bumbling clown pretending to be as famous uncle,
but living Napoleon was as stupid as his enemies.
Thought back in England,
he settled down to watch events unfolds,
just biding his time and he didn't have to buy it as time for very long.
On June the 23rd 1848 the work is a Paris revolted against the provisional
government's who felt that they had betrayed the revolution.
The results was the June days,
a three day massacre,
which soul 1,500 Parisians being killed when he was that the second republic,
it's still stood to bid.
Those connected to as well.
Now even less popular than the July Monica had been.
Now all of this,
if at Louis Napoleon in an excellent position on September the 17th to the 18th
1848 France held elections for the constituent assembly.
Louis Napoleon got on the tickets in one five departments and with that the
assembly was forced to lift his exile.
Now legally back in France,
Louis Napoleon began campaigning and agentic Lee for the upcoming presidential
elections.
He ran his announcement of the populous promising extinction of pauperism to the
poor military discipline,
to the burner POTUS and to presidents untainted by the June days to everyone
else.
The results on December the 10th 1848 where a landslide Louis Napoleon Ramat
home with 74% of the vote,
the elites,
they will have to gasping in his dust.
This clown was now precedent.
Still.
His opponents comforted themselves with the knowledge that the new constitution
only allowed presidents one four year term by 1842 president Louis Napoleon,
it'd be gone.
I mean,
after all,
it's not like he had a habit of launching coups or anything like that,
right?
Let me Napoleon's motivations though they revealed themselves slowly.
The self styled prince presidents at first worked with a national assembly
supporting populist moves like sending the military to Rome to protect the pope
from revolutionaries.
In fact,
things went so slowly that nobody even seemed to notice the way that Louis
Napoleon was stuffing all the key posts in governments and the army with
loyalists,
kind of just like someone plotting a coup might do.
In 1851 Louis Napoleon finally came into the,
with his ambitions,
they asked the National Assembly to a men's,
the constitution to let him run again.
They said no.
So the prince presidents when they got rid of them December.
The second is a special day for Bonaparte Lists.
It's the day that the Polian was coronated in 1804 it's also the day that he
defeated the third coalition at the battle of Austerlitz in 1851 it also became
the day that Louis Napoleon finally did a COO,
right?
Overnight,
$30,000 loyalists occupied Paris.
People are woke to posters announcing the national assembly had been dissolved,
although some die hard republicans mans the barricades.
It's simply wasn't enough.
On December the fourth 1851 Paris fell,
President Bonaparte announced the effective dissolution of the second republic
then held a referendum just to check that this was cool with everyone and it
totally was the one with an enormous margin.
10 months later in November of 1852 he held another referendum on restoring the
friend Jen.
Byron's giving himself near unlimited power and yes,
he won that too.
I'll just have it.
The second 1852 the first anniversary of his cue,
Louis Napoleon was officially crowns.
Napoleon,
the third emperor of the second French and Bob,
this is what the famous column great about history repeating itself actually
refers to first as tragedy then as foss,
but what it Louis Napoleon cat it finally done it hit,
achieved the impossible dream that his mother had set for him back when they
were both living as exiles wells.
It'll laughed at him.
I did one now it was time to show them just how wrong they were.
What does a guy who's been lusting for power for basically his entire life do
when he finally gets it?
In the case of Napoleon the third,
the answer is well,
everything that once the period of 1852 to 1860 as known as the authoritarian
empire and it's the period where Napoleon,
the third road like a mad cross between a total deaths bought a liberal Utopian
Mandy kid on a sugar rush or running around trying to do a bazillion things at
once.
His biggest project was Paris,
but at the time the city of lights was actually more like the city of horrible
smells and all my God.
What's that floating in the sen?
The French capital was filthy.
Cholera outbreaks were common,
the streets were crowded,
slums.
Everything you probably picture as Paris in your mind today is exactly what the
city was,
not in 1850 to one of the Emperor Napoleon.
The third,
his first acts was to call architect baron Haussmann into his office and tell
him to go forth and it's bringing a light and cleanliness together.
The two men,
they roots the Paris street plan of today.
They knocked down slums,
built parks,
improved sanitation,
gave every worker at home created the sweeping boulevards that Paris is famous
for those elegant buildings that pop into your head whenever you hit Paris.
Well,
this is when they first appear.
It's also when Paris first gets its nickname.
Holsman installed so many gas streetlights that the capital was christened the
city of lights still Napoleon.
The third is rain.
It wasn't just construction work.
He made education and compulsory.
He lifted the ban on women gaining higher education.
He instituted public pensions and ushered in agricultural reforms that wipes out
famines in France permanently.
He also,
he made the stays invest heavily in railway and steamship building opens lines
of guaranteed credits to small business owners.
It was always like a new deal of the 1850s or maybe an old new deal and it
totally worked.
By 1870 the economy was growing at 5% a year.
Well,
industrial output had boomed by 75% in short,
the counts sends out,
so not ready.
The account at all.
Napoleon the third even managed to grab fronts and choice colonies like New
Caledonia,
equality in 1853 Vietnam,
1858 and Cambodia 1863 now we such a neat shouldn't gloss over his authoritarian
side while froms boomed economically,
socially,
it transformed into a police state.
There was censorship restrictions on association and free speech and there were
spies everywhere and then that was the Roth,
a sticky topic of war.
The period from the end of the Napoleonic wars until the rise of the second
friend Jen buyer,
it hadn't seen a single conflict between Europe's great powers,
barely was Napoleon.
The third is thrown warm from his imperial backside than the Crimean war erupted
in 1853 now,
the Crimean war is super complicated and then it would be unfair to blame.
It's all on the polio and the third,
but he was itching for a fight and he pressed forward where maybe others would
have backed down.
The result was a conflict that killed nearly a million people,
but left France and our ally Britain.
You live victorious on the European stage.
This confidence boost,
let's interns and Napoleon the third to getting involved with,
it's an the second war of unification in 1859 given Italian nationalists of
trying to assassinate him the year before,
throwing a bomb in his carriage that killed 14 of his entourage.
Yeah,
might've expected Napoleon the third.
Do you fight against unification?
But no,
he sent it the French army to help the Kingdom of Santine Arabia kick the
Austrians out of their Italian colonies.
They won that war too,
which is why nice and survive currently part of France by 1860 [inaudible] end
was riding high.
The stability and the 30 and reading made France great again.
It also convinced himself that he was a tactical military genius on par with
this legendary uncle [inaudible] Mary Countess [inaudible] need to Monte year.
They know what they say about pride.
It always comes before a full end to Louis Napoleon.
He was a legendary fool.
Historians of the seconds,
French embark all the period after 1860 the liberal empire.
Why?
Well,
it's the periods when Napoleon,
the third pivoted from being a nasty death spot to a slightly more cuddly one.
The transformation came in 1860 to head off a political crisis.
Over the huge loans is projects were racking up.
Louis Napoleon offered his Senate new powers and east censorship.
The changes were enough to keep them in power and led to more liberalization
down the line.
Yet all this is really just a sideshow to the two major events of 1862 the first
was something of a private problem looming.
Napoleon's rain had been partially held together by his boundless energy,
but in 1862 he developed exceedingly painful bladder stones that SAP has energy
left in reliance on those around him.
The second was far more consequential for world history and that was the rise of
Otto von Bismarck.
We've actually got another biographics graphics video in the works about
Bismark's.
I mean,
not going to get too sidetracked with him right here,
but just let me give you a very quick overview.
Bismarck was the minister president of pressure,
a geometric country roughly analogous to modern eastern Germany and northern
Poland's with its capital in Berlin.
Bismarck was a firm believer in both the strategic use of warfare as the
unification of all the many German statelets into a single Germany.
He was also a political genius.
He didn't take fools lightly,
which was a big problem.
Vore Louis Napoleon,
not that tiny pressure appeared much of a threat to France in 1862 when Bismarck
went to war against the Danes and 80 64 Napoleon the third barely even noticed
in October of 1865 living to podium even promise the iron chancellor,
France wouldn't intervene of pressure went to war with Austria less than a year
later.
These seven weeks war ended with Vienna beaten.
Louis Napoleon actually mediated the piece stalks which oversaw the creation of
the sort of half unified Germany,
the northern German confederation.
This was a problem because it was now clear that this thing called Germany was
becoming extremely big and extremely powerful in a very short space of time,
but Napoleon the third,
he was simply to arrogance or maybe too diluted to realize the threat that
Germany Post.
He still thought that he was the senior partner in the relationship with
Bismarck.
It wasn't until Bismarck blocks of the French annexation of Luxembourg by ending
war that Louis Napoleon realized that he was in over his head.
The big trouble was that everyone else realized it too.
When frons backs off on Luxembourg,
Bismarck was able to see just how weak the French empire was.
The French public,
they turned on their emperor in the 1869 elections.
The government nearly lost control of the centers by the end of 1869 Napoleon,
the third was forced to fully liberalized the empire just to keep power turning
it into a kind of constitutional monarchy.
Unfortunately,
the changement listening more than ever to what the public ones is and what the
public wants.
It was war with pressure
even by the standards of the 19th century.
The causes of the Frank Prussian war are ridiculous beyond belief in Spain,
Queen Isabella abdicated the throne and depression prints off a takeout place.
France said no and send their ambassador to tell the brush and gang to back off.
The ambassador met the king on a walk,
shouted at him for a minute,
and then stormed off and with that begins the Franco Prussian war.
All right,
so it was slightly more complicated than that.
In reality,
the real trigger was the ends dispatch,
which contains an accounts of the meeting between the king and the ambassador
that was perfectly calibrated to make both sides think that they'd been
grievously and salted.
It was edited by Bismark.
You by now had decided they quick war with the French would be the perfect
bonding exercise to seal German unification and they've got his wish.
On July the 19th 1870 France declared war on pressure.
The French army is 280,000 trips.
They were mobilized despite being shockingly ill by this stage.
Napoleon,
the third row down to do personally lead the troops,
amusingly his stuff,
so sure that they'd soon be conquering German territory that they forgot to pack
any maps of their own country.
The first engagement it game on August the fourth 1870 and it was a massacre.
The well trained Prussians made mincemeat out of in Napoleon's shambolic army
for two entire days after a staggering restraint.
The French fought again on August the 16th and again,
they were wiped out getting desperate.
Louis Napoleon tried to summon the spirit of his dead uncle.
He got that all remaining French soldiers for an attack on the Prussian troops.
Besieging mets.
This was exactly the sort of foolhardy gamble that his uncle would have made,
but the differences is uncle it have pulled it off on the 1st of September,
1870 the French and the Prussians fault,
the battle of sedan,
which could just as well be called the defeat of subtle,
the French,
they were pulverized.
The Prussians managed to and cycle and then capture that entire on a among those
arrested was living Napoleon.
When the news of the emperor's capture reached Paris on September the fourth the
government was so outraged it voted then and that to abolish the second friend
Jamba along with its useless emperor Franz immediately became the third
republic.
It wasn't the end of the world.
I am drags on it through the grueling siege of Paris,
but certainly we need to pay her.
Then it was done living to pay it.
It was kept prisoner until the P street.
He was signed and the unification of Germany was declines on January the 18th
1871 finally,
in March,
the now former emperor was released back into exile and England's but has
humiliations.
They were not done yet.
In the wake of France is epic defeat.
Paris was seized by a radical revolutionary group that became known as the Paris
commune.
They ruled for two months before putting Paris to the torch.
When the French army retook the city,
the new Paris,
there's Louis Napoleon had spent so long building was simply burned to the
ground.
Although it would be ultimately rebuilt to his designs,
it would never live to see us over in England's Louis.
Napoleon had settled in the village of Chisel Hurst with his wife and their son,
who they still call it the prince and burial.
It was a short and painful retirements looming.
Napoleon's health got worse until on January the ninth 1873 he went to the
hospital for a last ditch operation to care is bladder stones.
He died under the knife at age 65 all of those times it listened to his mother
as a young Exxon and dreamed of being emperor.
He could have never imagined that it would end like this.
In 1879 looming up aliens and the prints and perio also died.
Extinguishing their family is line two years later,
his wife,
Janie has both of them re buried and Farnborough pleasantly boring towns,
some 30 miles from London.
Although the tomb that holds Napoleon,
the third remains a tourist attraction.
It's hardly as if a lead.
So what's in the ends to Louis Napoleon accomplish?
Well,
the road fronds for longer than his uncle did since he undoubtedly oversaw an
industrial boom that modernized the French economy.
If founded colonies like New Caledonia,
that's still departments of France today.
On z promoted workers and women's rights at a time when it was deeply
unfashionable.
On the other hands,
he took France from a peaceful states back to one of dangerous warfare and paid
a catastrophic Lee high price.
The peace settlements after the Franco Prussian war crippled France all the way
into a world war one.
But perhaps the biggest thing that the other emperor Bonaparte's accomplished
was becoming the other ember of Bonaparte's.
This was a man who as a child was bands from his home country,
false,
live in exile and derided as a clown,
yet through shit Dawg,
it determination,
he managed to conquer the very system that had locked him out.
If only for a brief time.
Was he a clown?
Was he a tyrant?
Was he a visionary leader that down by one disastrous naps in judgements?
Well,
the jury's still out on that one,
but there's one thing we cannot deny Louis Napoleon.
He was and will forever be Napoleon,
the third emperor of the French.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Do not forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several times a week,
so hit that subscribe button,
hit that thumbs up,
and you'll find out.
It's about all of those.
If you're looking for something else to watch,
they why not check out my other channel called top ten's.
You'll find a link to that on the screen now as well as below this video,
and as always,
thank you for watching.